Hey everyone, it's Mike from OrderFlows
here and welcome back to my channel. I'm
glad you could join me for today's
video. I'm going to be talking about the
market generated information that you're
going to find in the order flow. So,
before we jump in, if you've been
enjoying learning from my videos, don't
forget to subscribe and click the
notification bell so you don't miss any
new upload. And if you find today's
video helpful, hit the like button for
me and leave a comment sharing your
biggest takeaway. You know, I love
hearing your feedback. Often times I do
make videos based off of your
suggestions that I find in the comments.
So, your support really does go a long
way in helping me create more content
just like this. So, again, if you're
getting value from my channel, be sure
to
hit the subscribe button. Okay, so what
I'm going to talk about I'm going to
talk about it's the gold market today
cuz gold was quite interesting. I'll
just pull up the chart here real quick.
You know, we had this nice big rally
take place in the gold from our lows
around 44 up to new highs at 54, all
right? And you know, we
spent uh you know, Friday we sort of
closed around 45.
So, you know, we're about $10 higher
right now. But, I want to talk about
what's taking place right here in the
order flow that can give you some decent
signs of what's going to happen later
when we come back up to that area, okay?
Because once we got past this area, it
really became a springboard to higher
prices.
All right, so let's take a look at the
footprint, okay? So, this is your basic
uh
order flow footprint chart, right? You
know, with the volume on the bid and
volume on the offer.
And
probably around uh 8:25 this morning,
all right? We sort of hit these areas up
in here around the 49 and uh 4970-ish
area, okay? I'm just going to draw a
line here cuz we're going to come back
to this in a second.
But, you know, in order flow, there's a
lot of information, right? There's a lot
of
numbers and you know, things that you're
looking at
in the volume, okay? And one of the
things I like to focus on, which in my
opinion is a great piece of market
generated information. What's market
generated information? It's simply
information that is generated by the
market, right? I mean, it's nothing
complicated. And what that means is, you
know, it's like a support or resistance
area based off of the volume, okay? Now,
I could look at this volume, right? We
just rallied up to the swing high up
here, and I see a nice big volume coming
through here at uh
4970, 194970, 134 contracts, right? And
even, you know, sort of preceding it on
the way up, I see there's 78 here, 71,
70, and we hit that area, come off a
little bit, going sideways. I get this
point of control right up here on the
extreme of the red candle, a decent
volume up here at 34, and then the
market sells off, okay? Now,
years ago, right? Before I even started
the orderflows.com website and and doing
all that, you know, when I was trading
with order flow, what I did is is I
literally went through
charts, right?
I don't know how many thousands of days
of of charts, because, you know, it's
not just one market, but all the other
markets,
um you know, gold, silver, you know,
bonds, fives, tens, minis,
um
currencies, all that, to I to take a
look at how markets top out, and what
are some of the signs of a market
topping out in because
you know, all day long, right? Markets
make swing highs, make swing lows. And
if there was something in the order flow
that I could
identify, sort of pick out in, you know,
by by going through all these different
charts, you know, something tangible
that, you know, if I see the market come
up to a swing high, I could say, "Aha,
I've seen that before. I know what to
do." And that is why in the order flows
trader, right? We have a lot of tools in
there because these tools that you know,
I developed is they were developed for a
specific reason. Right? Because it was
something I've seen in the order flow in
the past, right? I didn't just copy
these ideas from other
softwares out there. These are my own
ideas that I put in there. And one of
them is the whole concept of prominent
point of controls. Okay? And you can see
I got level 1, 2, and 3. But I'm just
going to focus on this level 3 prominent
point of control. Okay?
And I'm just going to click apply.
And it's going to show me, right, the
point of controls that matter. This is
what I talk about when I talk about
market generated information.
The point of control is the price level
in the bar with the most volume.
Okay, what does that mean? Well, it's
telling me that, you know, that's an
area where traders were happy to
transact the most volume in a bar. Okay?
And And you know, honestly, every bar is
going to have one, right? And often
times the point of control should come
somewhere around the middle of the bar,
like here, right? In the middle here,
kind of close to the middle, kind of the
middle,
uh the middle, the middle, you know,
mostly the middle. Even on the way down,
the middle, the middle. But what I found
is, you know, when a market is sort of
topping out, you know, swing high,
doesn't have to be high of the day, you
know, and I'm seeing the heavy volume
sort of transacting up near the high of
the bar, that's going to be important.
That's a level that if the market starts
to react from right now,
I also want to pay attention to when it
comes back to that level later. Okay?
So, before going forward, right? Cuz
this was an interesting level, right? We
came up here.
Um 4970, you traded four contracts at
4980, but we hit 4970 for some decent
volume up in here. Okay? And earlier,
a little bit earlier, actually even uh
this was about 7:20, so about an hour
prior,
um you even got a bearish point of point
of control coming in up here at the
swing high at 4920, right? This is 4970,
which we hit a little bit earlier. So, I
in the back of my head, I'm sort of
thinking that as we're coming back up to
4920, right? Over here, 4920, we may run
into more size, and we do, right? You
can see the 78 here, the 71, the 70.
Okay, now we hit that 4970 area, right?
And the market starts selling off. I
know I've got supply up in here.
You know, basically between
you know, earlier we had at 4920, but
it's there from 4920 on up, maybe even
as high as 50, okay? But what's
important is the market is reacting to
the supply here, and then the market
sells off, right? We sell off from 4970,
we get back down into the 4570 area, so
about
you know, a $4
move.
All right? Then we go down, and then we
actually make new lows down here at
4380.
Then we start going back up, okay? So,
as we start going back up, where's my
market generated information? It's up
here at this blue line, right? That I
drew earlier at 4970. So, we're at 43,
you know, 80 is the low. We start going
up, and again, some nice um
bullish signs in the order flow. We're
seeing some supportive buying coming in.
How do I know there's supportive buying
coming in? Cuz I'm seeing big
bigger volumes on the bid than on the
offer. I see 145 here, I see a 172 here.
That's what I like to see on a market
that's moving up.
And then we get back up, right? Again,
4980 or 4970. We do come up to 4890,
some you know, and sort of bounce off,
going sideways. And then we get right
back up here. We get within a couple of
ticks, right?
We get up to 4960. Again, 4970 is my
level, trade to sort of come off. That's
the first sign that it's
running sort of into this market
generated information level of supply.
And how do I know that? Well, I'm
putting in one, two, three point of
controls more or less at the same area.
Two are coming in at 49
and a half, one is coming in at 4940.
This is a bearish prominent point of
control.
Okay, but we are trading. That's where
the size is trading, just right below
that
resistance area where there's identified
earlier in the order flow that there was
supply in the market. Okay, then the
market just, you know, it's just hanging
around there. Doesn't really sell off,
comes back up again.
Decent volume coming through at 4930.
Again, my my level's just right here at
4970.
Just hanging around there, right? It's
not selling off. So, what do I have? I
have a market that's
going into
resistance.
And every time it sort of gets in there,
it just stops. It's not selling off yet.
Okay, so maybe, you know, you got to
start thinking, well, okay, I know I
have resistance. I know I have supply
here.
What should happen? Well, if your market
runs into supply and it's a legitimate
level, it's going to hold. But if a
market runs into supply
and obviously you're coming up into a
supply area,
and they're they're buying it, right?
Traders are buying it, but at the same
time, you know, you got to
think also that
the supply in the market is selling as
well, right?
And then something's going to happen.
You're either going to break through or
you're going to sell off. Cuz it's not
going to just stay here at the supply
level all day long.
But this is the key part here. We get
through this supply level at 4970.
Right? And people say, well, why why
weren't you trading a little bit closer
to 4970? Well, from earlier, right? I
actually that I
it at Remember this point of control
here?
Go back.
At 720, right? You sort of ran into this
area. Uh we'll take this prominent point
of control.
Okay, here. So, it was 4920 up to 4970,
basically, which
we're bouncing around in there.
Get up here.
Bouncing around right in that area
again. Now we get through it here, okay?
This is where it gets interesting.
How do I know that this breakout
is legitimate? Because now we're
breaking out beyond
a resistance level.
Okay?
That's a breakout. But, as you know, not
all breakouts work, right? A lot of
times breakouts fail. How can we have
some sort of confidence that this
breakout probably got some legs to it?
Well, then you just look at the
footprint,
right?
What's the volume doing? Well, you see
some strong volumes coming in here. 104
on the bid, 130 on the bid.
Okay? 63 on the bid, 63 on the bid. So,
I know that there's some strong
passive buyers. There's people there
supporting the market. Cuz remember, you
know,
technical analysis 101,
previous resistance becomes support.
Now you're seeing supportive buying
coming in in the form of strong passive
buyers. I mean, earlier did you see
anything in 100 lots coming in here? No.
But now that you got through this
resistance area, now you're seeing
supportive buying coming in.
104, 130, you know, 63, 68, 63.
Okay?
It goes up, makes a new high.
Then it comes off and it sells off
where?
Right into your previous resistance area
again. But we know that
there's a good chance that this previous
resistance area is going to be support
when we saw the supportive buying coming
in and it trades literally right down to
that 4920 area and just sort of hangs
around here. But where where we hanging
this time? We're hanging above
the resistance area.
Right? Because now it's become support.
Then it starts to ticking higher,
ticking higher and then, you know, just
by looking at the footprints, you can
see where is the volume coming in. Well,
there's decent volume here. There's 48.
You know, a 32, a 32, a 48, a 63. You
know, 3119.
So, if anything, chances are we're
probably going to go higher. And
eventually we just pop up to new highs
and just keep going
up to new highs here. New high, new
high, new high and new high.
Right? New high. And where are we right
now? I think yeah, 3853.
But
the sign was there. When you broke out
right here,
you broke out of your resistance area,
identifying that, hey, you know what,
this resistance is probably now going to
act as support.
So, if you can identify that that
resistance area, that that breakout
is legitimate, cuz again, if a breakout
is legitimate,
what was resistance should become
support for the market to go higher.
Right? Here, this was your resistance
earlier, basically.
Right here. From here
to here,
breakout
right here,
pull back into your now support
to go much higher.
And this is, you know, people say,
"Well, it's not a big a move." It is.
It's a $500 move.
50 all the way up to 55 before settling
in around 53, which is where we're at
right now.
So, again, you know,
that's to me, you know, sort of one of
the the nuances of understanding the
volumes, where they're coming in in the
order flow, and sort of putting these
pieces together of the market generated
information. You know, I like to talk a
lot about um what I'm seeing right now,
all right? In the heat of the moment,
okay? But, when you
can put the pieces together,
right? And this is where something like
the prominent point of control is really
really help, all right? By identifying
these areas right here. I mean, you can
trade, you know, these prominent point
of controls by themselves
to catch a move like this, you know,
from, you know, 49
down to 45.
But then, not only that, you should
still keep them in your rear view mirror
so that when the market comes back to
those levels,
you can be looking for a market to react
to it, or
check it, see how it's
acting as support or resistance. Again,
these are bearish prominent point of
controls. It's a bullish one down here,
you know, a bullish one in the middle of
the move.
Um but again, you know, that that's why
you see all these tools in our order
flow trader software. It's cuz they're
designed for a specific use in the
market, right? Based off of how I trade,
because, you know, anytime a market
makes a high or low, it does leave
clues.
And then, anytime a market gets through
a previous high or low, whether it's a
swing high or swing low, it's going to
leave clues. You got to look for those.
So,
that's going to wrap up this video on
sort of market generated information,
you know, using the order flow. So, I
hope you found these tips helpful for
your understanding of order flow. Let me
know what you like to discuss next by
leaving a comment below.
I I you've enjoyed this video. Make sure
you hit the like button and subscribe to
my channel so you don't miss any of my
upcoming videos. So, thanks so much for
watching and being part of my community.
I'll catch you guys on the next video.
Bye-bye.